is NAD and creatine okay to take.
I have a blog post on creatine,
the pros and cons for cancer,
and my ultimate,
the quick answer to that is probably not.
NAD is nicotidamide
and adicine.
I forgot.
And that is usually considered an anti-aging supplement.
NAD is a big new anti-aging supplements,
a big new supplement to help in boost.
Circulation for people that are working out.
It's big in the workout spectrum.
It's big in the anti-aging spectrum.
It has positives and negatives to it for somebody who has cancer.
I would say if your cancer is in full remission,
there's a problem with it.
It can be good for your heart,
it can boost at your oxide levels.
If your cancer is active,
I would say no on NAD.
If your cancer is in full remission
and you're looking for other things,
then I would say looking for things,
let's say you have heart issues
or you have,
you're trying to work out,
you're trying to increase circulation,
then that's a possibility.